نحن هنا في الاجزاء الجنوبيه لمحافظه
خانيونس حيث اليات الاحتلال انسحبت قبل
ايام من تلك المنطقه لكن هذا الانسحاب ليس
انسحابا كليا المواطنون يحاولون بين الحين
والاخر الوصول الى منازلهم وفي طريقهم الى
تلك المنازل يشاهدون عديد من الشهداء
والجثمان في طريقهم باتجاه منازلهم وكذلك
عدد من الاصابات قبل قليل وصل عدد من
المواطنين الى هذه المنطقه بعد ان انهوا
جولتهم الاستطلاع داخل المنطقه وداخل
الاماكن التي تتواجد فيها منازلهم وتحدثوا
عن شهداء
واصابات في الشوارع والطرقات في منطقه
جيزان النجار ومنطقه الكليه وغيرها من
المناطق سواء جوره اللوت وغيرها من
المناطق التي وصلوا
اليها الوضع دمار مش طبيعي ثامين شهداء
عباره عن هياكل عظميه لا يكسوها لحم ولا
اي شيء كم شهيد تقريبا شف تقريبا ما يقارب
من 10 الى 15 شهيد
دخول الدبابات من عند النادي ونزلت على
المحكمه وعلى الهداء ونزلت على الكليه في
كذا خبطه في مباني الكليه وهذا نعم هذا هو
الواقع وهذه الظروف الصعبه التي تفرضها
قوات الاحتلال على مناطق كثيره من قطاع
غزه في ظل استمرار العدوان الاسرائيلي على
القطاع والذي يتوسع في الاج
الجنوبيه من القطاع تحديدا في مدينه خان
يونس اوضاع غايه في الصعوبه وظروف يتحدث
المواطنون عن ظروف صعبه ايضا نتيجه
استمرار العدوان الاسرائيلي وهناك حديث عن
عدد كبير من الشهداء ملقا جثامينهم على
الارض وفي الطرقات في اكثر من منطقه من
محافظه خنوس سواء في المناطق الشرقيه
المناطق الغربيه وكذلك في وسط
المحافظه اسماعيل ابو عمر قناه الجزيره
خونس